so what what they set up is in part a
they say find the equations of the
chords of contact from here and here on
this parabola the equation for the court
of contact is X X naught equals what do
you know
okay 2a y plus y naught you're excellent
and why not we'll come from these
coordinates that's that point that's off
the parabola and then a you have to work
out so how do you do that okay so you've
got x squared equals 4 ey up here except
instead of for a you see an 8 so
therefore you can infer that a in this
case is equal to 2 make 8 a is going to
be equal to 2 in this case right so
really I can use this form having
substituted in a equals 2 and then you
do it for each of these two points okay
so can you tell me what the two
equations are what's this one X minus 4
1 a plus 4 equals 0 okay can we get the
UM can we also get the like
slope-intercept form for this plus 4 on
4 so I'll make the X plus 4 plus 1 yeah
okay cool all right
yeah that's perfect yeah okay great now
what does this mean we've got a diagram
sort of I've started to draw up a
diagram and it's because I want to
understand spatially what's happening
you saw how useful it was in the last
question so I could work out what on
earth is happening to be able to have a
diagram there even if it's a really
awful looking diagram it you just needed
as a visual sort of crutch to lean on ok
now I can work out what these things
look like on here right 1/2 X is going
to go through the origin and then it
seemed to sort of gently go up ok to me
it looks like that's gonna be something
like
that okay now I'm not going to put it on
because it's going to make this diagram
visually too busy P you can see that why
that makes sense because this is the
court of contacts from P right what
makes the court of clients the
definition of the court of contact how
would you describe to someone who's
never heard of such an object before
it's the cord that what okay yeah yeah
yeah very good so it's it's the cord
whose ends are from the points of
intersection with the tangents do you
agree so can you picture the tangents
sort of going like that can you picture
the tangents shrimpie can you picture
them here they are right there are the
tangents from P so that's why you've got
your quarter contact there okay then you
get this sky which I am guessing will
look something like this note that it is
shallower that the original chord of
contact it's shallower because of why
why is it shallow yeah the gradient is a
quarter and it's it's been shifted
upwards there's my there's my want it's
a terrible scale you get the idea okay
so I've put them at the same point
because the question said they're going
to intersect at R which is P Q is
tangent to the parabola at R so R is
somewhere on the parabola do you see how
I actually could reason that even though
I don't know where R is it has to be
somewhere on there and that has to be it
because I'm going to get a tangent all
right lastly what am i required to prove
okay so this is my goal I want to prove
that this is the tangent let's see how
bad this is gonna turn out okay there
you go so this is do you have a visual
now this is where I'm going okay so how
do I prove it there are there are two
pieces to this first I've got to work
out where R is right the chords
intersect at are well I have the
equations of the two courts so R is not
that hard to find let's do that okay if
the equations are y equals 1/2 x and y
equals 1/4 x plus 1
we want to do I'm looking for a point of
intersection so I'm gonna solve
simultaneously yeah
you could but that's a bit uh yeah
that's that's breaking an egg with a
sledgehammer I really don't need to do
something that involved so I'm going to
just substitute I'm just going to equate
the two all right now tell me what to do
yeah that'll that'll do me so that will
give me 2x that will give me X and
that'll give me plus four
now what yep I'm going to subtract X
from both sides which leaves me with
that okay which by the way I know it's
an awful diagram but it's like yeah you
know what that's that's not bad
right like you say okay so this is this
is good this is confirmation if I'd
gotten something negative even though my
diagram is rubbish I already know that's
wrong oh I did some arithmetic issue a
problem okay x equals four that means Y
is going to be two so far so good which
also is confirmation okay roughly so I'm
suggesting here that that's where R is
okay now my goal is to prove that PQ is
a tangent at that point we did something
like this in the previous question about
proving that something has attended
something else any suggestions from
anyone in the room now maybe you've had
enough time to catch up mentally okay
how do I prove that PQ is tangent to
this parabola at that point how did we
do it last time we use the discriminant
which was reliant on the fact that we
had the equation of the parabola we had
the equation of this tangent I'm gonna
not say teja I don't know that yet we
have the equation of this line which
I'll point out we don't currently know
and then we use the discriminant we
found it was equal to zero in fact in
that case we set it to be zero because
we wanted it to be a tangent that could
work you there anything else we could do
R is this point up here that's our I'm
happy to use that method is there
anything else we could do that
I'm interested in looking at another
method because I mean we just use the
discriminant can we can we flex the
muscles and try something else
yeah I absolutely could yeah if I find
the derivative then I can work out what
the derivative is at that point what I
want is for it to match the derivative
of this straight line okay it sounds
like for either of the options I'm going
to go through I need the equation of the
tangent I need to find the equation of
PQ so let's do that okay
the equation of PQ have a look at the
information you've got what am I going
to do to find the equation I can find
the gradient there and then I can put
one of the points in alternatively
because I don't already know what the
gradient is I could just use two point
form because two-point form does both of
those all in one here right so I'm going
to do that Y minus y1 X minus x1 you see
right there on the right hand side
that's the calculation of the gradient
yeah so let's go ahead and do this which
one you ought to be x1 y1 which would
you prefer you think it should be this
one here yeah okay let's do it yeah
that's fine
that's okay so I'm going to mentally
what I often do is once I set that one I
do all of the things in relation to that
so I do all of these guys all in one
here so I'm going to go - 0 - 2 - 0 - 2
okay the reason I do this by the way is
just an exam technique when I flop back
and forth between one of my substituting
I often mix up what I'm substituting
into what and then I just make a
numerical error which is the most
frustrating kind of error to make so
there's Y and X what's x - y - yep so
there's the minus one and there's the
one that look good Y X minus 2 yeah this
is negative 1 or negative 1 that's
convenient y equals x minus 2 sense
check what do you think looks ok yeah
I will point out I had to stop myself as
I was drawing this because the scale I
had originally chosen made it really
hard to draw so that's why if you have a
look at odd that's one on the x-axis but
this is one on the y-axis I made it a
quite different so that it would be a
nicer shape and yeah that sure looks a
whole lot like negative 2 right so
thumbs up what was I gonna do with this
okay yeah fantastic so I can already I
can immediately read off that the
gradient is going to be 1 okay so now in
order to prove that this is a tangent I
need to show it number one the gradient
there at are on the parabola is also 1
and I also have to prove that this goes
through ah okay that's not hard let's do
it
I can prove that this goes through are
without any calculus so I'll do that
first it's very very easy the quality of
our this right so if I substitute how
will I do this
4 comma 2 into this right I'm gonna do
the right hand side equals 4 minus 2 yes
which equals 2 which equals the left
hand side as required because there's my
y-coordinate okay so therefore my
conclusion from this little point is
therefore are lies on P Q that's not
enough to make an attachment now I need
to go through the gradient
okay so what's dy/dx for this parabola
yeah so since the parabola is x squared
on eight once I differentiate I get X on
four is that okay so when X is equal to
four which is where R is right do you
wanna do X equal surprise surprise one
there we go
I'm done I found that it goes through
there same gradient that is exactly what
the definition of a tangent is